[Music]
Hey ladies bra bulge and also unpaid fat
while most of us can't get a little
self-conscious especially when we're in
sleeveless tops the good news is you can
turn up this area with regular strength
training and security exercises so
today's workout will focus on your
shoulder muscles your chest muscles and
also your back muscles to reduce the
appearance of your unfit fat and a sub
bra bulge okay so get your body warmed
up and let's do this workout together
[Music]
what you'll need is a pair of really
lightweight dumbbells between two to
three kilos each if you don't have any
dumbbells fill up any bottles with water
or rocks okay so the first workout is
going to be a hinge to reverse fly stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward I want you to bend down
from your waist
give me a reverse fly squeeze your back
and hinge up okay
let's go 45 seconds for each workout up
squeeze your lower back and feel your
shoulders and a little bit on your chest
so squeeze your back up and really
squeeze your upper back feel your upper
back and you'll see your shoulders
working spread your wings all right good
spread your elbows to the side okay the
longer your arms extend to the side the
more you will work on your shoulders and
you will feel your upper back good hinge
very good so squeeze the gluts right at
the top good squeeze the glutes and open
up spread those wings ladies this
workout is really good for your back and
your shoulders good rest it out second
workout is called round the world okay
so I want you to start with your elbows
in a ninety degree position okay squeeze
it together through your chest bring it
up and open up control bring it together
and bring it back up okay let's go so
open squeeze push it up round the world
good bring it back up close it and bring
it down open and squeeze the chest up
bring it open control and up good bring
it back down open and squeeze again up
feel your chest feel your shoulder
muscles control nice and control back up
good back down 90 degrees open squeeze
the chest squeeze dump it muscles good
yep your entire body has muscles okay
it's just a matter of working on them
down open up right now we want to get
down onto the mat okay so the next
workout is going to be a breech fly get
down to the mat with your heels on to
the floor lift your butt off dumbbells
up okay just like reverse fly I went to
spread your arms to the side and close
it and squeeze and feel your chest
muscles and also the muscles around your
um pit area just like any workouts you
have to control the dumbbells okay so
spread your wings to the side okay
elbows close to the floor tap gently and
bring it back up good
so the dumbbells should be at chest
level it should not be too high advocate
this is wrong it should be a chest level
open and squeeze good remember to
squeeze your butt okay
there's a bonus here you're also working
on your butt
good open up open squeeze control one
more open and squeeze good now drop the
dumbbell we want to get into own white
and also narrow push-ups so the white
push I will work on your chest
you'll never push I will work on your
triceps alright so find your starting
point you can either start on your knees
wide to narrow push up okay white to
never push ups good to really focus on
your tricep muscles good keep your
elbows pointed back weak a tricep
push-ups okay white elbow spread up
narrow elbows point
as you progress get on two toes white
narrow bring you down and up good nice
and control wide to narrow ladies
push-ups are sooo good for you okay keep
going
I know you hate push-ups but keep going
white narrow few more and rest it's not
you have one last final workout okay lie
on to your belly this is going to be a
little bit challenging alright so what
I'm going to do is lift the dumbbells to
your side okay and bring it back squeeze
leave it to your side drop down gently
lift up and squeeze good down up and
squeeze good if this is to each other to
drop the dumbbells down up and squeeze
good to really lift your lower back
squeeze your triceps working up and
squeeze okay
as you progress lift a little lighter up
and squeeze down up and squeeze good do
more down up and squeeze and last one up
and squeeze all right good
drop the weights and you can take a
one-minute break we want to go on to set
number two
[Music]
[Music]
you have about 15 seconds left okay you
know all the exercises give me your best
shot
okay let's aim to do each workout for
one minute long without any break so the
first workout is going to be hinge to
reverse fly okay I want you to really
focus on squeezing your upper back and
keep your knees slightly bent and soft
let's go bend down for your waist
squeeze it and up very good so open up
spreading wings control and up remember
every time you bring the dumbbells down
it's about controlling the width that's
when you will work more on your own
muscles and also your back open squeeze
control and up okay
it's not about arching but rather it's
about squeezing of gluten muscles good
spread your wings control and view your
lower back as well spread and very good
keep going ladies feel your upper back
feel your chest muscles and feel your
shoulders as well good you're doing a
good job
give me another 15 seconds okay let's
not stop now
good very good remember to pace your
breathing breathe in and out and we want
to move on to the second workout which
is round the world let's go open squeeze
up open control almost touching bring it
back up down open it squeeze the chest
straight up
open round-the-world clothes and back up
feel your shoulders bring it back down
not too low 90 degrees back up and open
it up good nice and control okay
it's not about rushing the workout it's
about engaging your muscles spread it
wide bring it in bring it up and down
good keep going okay
one minute solid workout open squeeze
ten more seconds okay let's not stop now
and we want to get straight down on to
the mat for bridge fly good bring it up
and open let's get back down onto the
floor get straight into a bridge okay
dumped us in front of you spread your
wings into a nice flight good control
squeeze your chest muscles you should
feel the side of your chest muscles
which is where your bra bulge area is
all right good control open up tap
gently and control the wider you open
your arms the more you will feel your
chest muscles working as well as your
arms okay
every time you control the dumbbells
that's when you will work more on your
arm muscles so nice and control and
squeeze the chest good open up and
squeeze okay lift your body high up
we're going for one minute let's not
stop right now and squeeze good squeeze
give me last one okay just one more and
we want to get straight into push-up
drop your dumbbells let's get into a
wide and narrow push-up ok choose your
option you can start learning is what
you can do to challenge yourself is to
hop in 20 elbows back pop back out into
a wipe hop in narrow point your elbows
back and wipe good there you go
that little momentum will make you work
harder on your triceps and there so your
chest muscles very good nice and control
point your elbows back and pointing
elbows out chest down really now almost
touching the mat okay and hop back in
very good good keep going and breathe in
and breathe out through your triceps
good
give me another 15 seconds okay let's
not stop right now
at least three more push-ups let's go
one two one more three and grab your
baby it's okay
this is going to be challenging again
like I said choose your option you can
start without any weight spread your
arms to your side and squeeze in your
triceps lift your lower back up and
squeeze in very good so spread to the
side squeeze and squeeze okay to add a
little bit of challenge lift the weight
to your sight squeeze your triceps and
squeeze good speakit glutes as well good
last where I got a key squeeze and
squeeze very good keep going you have
five seconds left squeeze to the side
squeeze
you're up the way very good now get into
a Chows pose right very very well done
okay so that workout will work on your
Bravo area and also your unpick that
area so the goal is to target your
shoulders your chest and also your arm
muscles alright so remember to combine
this workout with your regular cardio
exercises do this workout three to four
times weekly for best results if you
want to challenge yourself
well replay this video and do it once
more
go on share this video with the
girlfriends and don't forget to hit the
like button and also subscribe to my
youtube channel if you haven't done it
for a lot more workout videos workout
challenges and really healthy and
delicious recipes all the best and I'll
see you in my next workout